how do you perform while you're on your
opinions
[Music]
hi my name is ava mystic and I'm a comm
model hi my name is nikita banks and i'm
a cam model and today we'll be answering
questions that you've always had about
cami what is the most unique prop or
costume you've used on camera my gadgets
like the toys that I use on camp oh
vampire costume yeah there is one toy
where the person on the other side of
the camera can control the toy so it's
it's awesome does your family know what
you do at this moment my family does
know but at the beginning when I started
like four years ago I was kind of afraid
of the reaction inevitably I had to have
this conversation with my parents when I
told my mom she was pretty shocked but I
mean she didn't should not me or
anything and we got over it and it's all
good have you ever become attracted to a
client to a client before not just one
more I really discovered some members
there that are extremely smart and wise
so yes I was attracted but more like its
first to mind the way they talk it never
goes further than online it doesn't go
any further because we kind of know what
it's all about how do you perform one
your opinion but the question I did that
aspect about this I prefer not to bill
for words you go in line when I am on my
period we have a whole week to get to
know each other getting intimate if you
are smart enough they are in other ways
then being mute in order to attract
someone and you can always use your
voice your smile your eyes what is the
most money you've made in one
one thousand two hundred one thousand
and four hundred dollars around one
thousand dollars or something like that
what does nested talk tips you can give
think outside the box
you have to be more open to your
significant other about your desires
about your hidden some of my favorite
lines are why don't you come over here
and let me drain your balls just Oh in
any case be open what is the hardest
part of being a chemical there are a lot
of guys just calling us names because we
dare this job and even the guys that
visit those kind of sites they're
calling us names they're treating us not
so good so I think keeping our heads up
it's probably the hardest the hardest
part but at the same time the funnest I
guess is like dealing with the different
people and fetishes I think that's the
hardest part just because it can be kind
of draining at the same time though as
it being the hardest part I think it's
one of the best parts because you get to
just see all types of avenues of
different things and people do you have
any plans to change careers in the
future I think that when you start to be
like a young model it's like you have to
have some goals because it's very easy
to earn money so I think you should do
something wise with your money and
invest in something because you cannot
be all your life a camera that I would
love to have a house in mountains and
like to make it a cabin to check in
tourist I'm already in the mists of
trying to become a sex therapist so it's
just cut in the same realm I think this
kind of gives me kudos to move move on
and do that along with of course my
schooling I would
this job changing a lot before I was
starting I was really shy I could never
have the balls to say like this to like
to dominate the men or things like that
I was extremely shy being as a model can
be very creative very entertaining very
fun it's how you are you get to express
yourself in front of thousands of people
that discovered this many things about
myself I never knew that I can be
sensual come see us have fun talk
whatever
[Music]